you
every Tuesday our ion money series looks
at financial issues Americans face this
morning we focus on marriage and money
June is a very popular month for
weddings and according to the planning
website but not couples spend an average
of $34,000 nearly on their weddings last
year
Tony's shaking his head no money you
eloped you did that you did it well 80%
of couples say they set a budget for 45
percent said they went over it we asked
one New York bride and groom about their
pre-wedding finances we got engaged in
October we went to the park and they're
having a picnic and was playing guitar
and it was just a nice beautiful day and
then there it was a beautiful ring we
are getting married in Brooklyn we found
a beautiful venue an average wedding in
New York is seventy thousand dollars and
we want to do well below that so we set
a budget of $50,000 you have to
negotiate
everybody's negotiable the catering was
like eight or 10k the florist like 4k
right now we don't have joint anything
we just venmo back and forth which
that's crazy is it yeah it gets kind of
crazy if you are paying for your own
wedding
you all have to make sacrifices yeah we
didn't go on vacation for a while we
didn't yeah but it was worth it because
this is the wedding we want to have and
we don't have a choice but to pay for it
ourselves it's the most important day in
your life so it's gonna be incredible it
was super psyched and excited yeah CBS
News business analyst Jill Schlesinger
is here with important financial
reminders for the big day and beyond
Jill I'm so happy you're here free
financial advice well your schedule I
need to sit with you all day but I'm a
bit late I'm getting married in a couple
of weeks earlier so for people who are
just starting out they're planning what
are the financial issues and things that
should be on their checklist okay so for
the wedding itself we have to figure out
who's
contributing what gone are the days
where it's the bride's family is paying
for this the groom's family's painful
just figure out who is willing and able
to chip in and then you've got that
budget and we saw that number forty five
percent of people blow through their
budget but have the budget know what
you're going to spend and remember this
is an important day so I appreciate our
couple that said it's the most important
day of your life but you may think
forward and say well do I really want to
spend that much money because there's
gonna be a number another important day
where I might want to have that money
set aside three quarters a couple say
they're willing to take on debt for
their wedding jill is that a good idea
that is a terrible terrible idea that is
such a bad idea because as my father
likes you like to say to me way back
when a hundred years ago my father says
okay I'm one hand you've got a pile of
money on the other hand you have a dirty
cake knife so you really want to try to
say why are we going into debt for this
you can have a great wedding but things
that actually love the image of the
wedding for you is the dirty cake yeah
that's that's big al you know what can I
say so the thing that's really
interesting though is that people are
going into debt maybe for things that
they don't ultimately appreciate so we
have surveys out but say people said if
I had just invited fewer people that
would cut down the cost if I spent less
on the wedding planner flowers the type
of food no one is going to say at
Adriana's wedding which we're all
crashing uh you know what the food was
so good they're gonna say she looked
beautiful happy it was a wonderful event
so be careful why you're going into debt
also so there is the wedding and then
there's the marriage there's a 54% of
people according to one survey don't
actually discuss their finances or they
do only about half people half of people
discuss their finances before being
married don't you think you should have
that conversation ahead of time what do
you have a new package oh I got this
absolutely and that's a mind-blowing
statistic they're spending more time
planning their wedding than their
financial futures so what kind of
conversations are we talking about you
want to share information you want to
say this is how much debt I have this is
what my assets are and then you want to
come to a determination are we mad are
we gonna merge our money or are we going
to keep it separate it doesn't matter
you just have to come to an agreement if
one person loves to manage money then
let that person be the one who follows
the money if one person loves to run the
investments let her run the investments
but talk about it come up with a game
plan and of course revisit that game
plan every quarter you know don't do it
in the middle of a fight but have these
conversations good advice thank you I
also like what we discussed at this
table which is don't focus on the
wedding focus on celebrating the 15th
year or the 20th year that's where the
hard stuff starts I'll have you back to
talk about anniversaries all right
fantastic my aunt and uncle 60th
anniversary today congratulations Jill
thank you very much we ask people at
home to tell us whether they would sign
a prenup if their spouse asks them to on
our CBS this morning Facebook page
Jim will explain who should consider a
prenup during the break